let me pull up this story from the daily
basis a good example Joe Rogan says it's
a fact that January 6 was a false flag
cites Ray Epps now that's a misleading
headline if I've ever seen one but of
course that's The Daily Beast if you are
someone who only consumes garbage
nonsense like The Daily Beast you might
think Joe Rogan's this crazy Alex Jones
guy
however fortunately for Joe Rogan he's
like one of the most famous people on
the planet and many of his fans know who
he really is these smears they don't go
very far but let me read this for you
they say wildly popular podcaster Joe
Rogan once again pushed baseless the
baseless conspiracy theory I love that
at the January 6 Capital Insurrection
was a false flag orchestrated by the by
the federal government adding that
pro-trump Riot or Ray Epps clearly
instigated the attack now hold on there
a minute Ray Epps is on camera
the night before and the day of telling
people to go to the Capitol and go in
the building he's then seen whispering
in someone's ear and he's on the front
line as the people breach the capitol
grounds
curious they didn't go after him the
feds didn't go after him he was
protected by the media defended by the
media and even now they're trying to
obfuscate what he did it's fascinating
isn't it earlier this month app sued Fox
News for defaming him this we know and
in that lawsuit we're hearing the Epps
may actually be facing criminal charges
they go to mention that Rogan's got a
contract with Spotify blah blah blah
Rogan said the intelligence committee
had a vested interest in this going
sideways adding that if somebody wanted
to disparage a political party or to
maybe have some sort of justification
for getting some influential person like
Trump Offline that would be the way they
would do it and Joe Rogan is completely
correct he was talking to Jim Gaffigan
who did not know anything about this I
gotta tell you when I listen to Joe
Rogan talk to Jim Gaffigan you know I'm
a political guy like I sit here I read
all this news I am just like shaking
wanting to talk to these guys you should
get gath again on the show and be like
ask me any question and I will answer it
and I will show you all the sources I
will pull them up one at a time and you
can by all means not believe the
guardian or NPR the New York Times just
you got to have some standard do you
believe his outs or not do you believe
political or not okay well that's what
we're basing this off of but Jim doesn't
know anything yeah he doesn't know
anything about it so what did Joe Rogan
really say
he said they never went after Ray Epps
he's seen on camera instigating the
stuff makes you wonder and now we know
what he said was a fact is that there
were guys there who were uh intelligence
assets encouraging people or I shouldn't
say I should say some kind of government
agent or law enforcement this is not
controversial this is confirmed yeah
they're admitted to doing it to going
let's go let's go hey go go and pushing
people towards the capital oh is that
admitted that agents pushed people
towards the capital there's there's body
camera footage of people who associated
with law enforcement I'd have to pull
this up I'll be very careful here
because I want to make sure we're
getting it right but they're saying
things like go go go when questioned I
think it was uh the FBI said we cannot
like answer were there people involved
at all yeah yeah they pled the fifth
basically and I I did see that clip and
that and and Joe I Joe Rogan cited Epson
he cited you know the FBI director
pleading the fifth
um but yeah it was like early on there
was like very early on after gen six
there was a New York Times article and
it was like federal agent you know
describes his experience on gen six so
um it's long been acknowledged that
there were federal agents in gen six I
think the strongest uh an argument for
false flag though is the pipe bomb which
apparently they have footage of like the
guy who put it there and they apparently
know where he lives to they've they've
like I I forget where I heard this but
they they know his address and yet they
have not
um prosecuted him or you know explained
what he whether it was a pipe bomb or
not you know what I mean they they it
doesn't look like they've investigated
what that was well that's scandalous
because that guy's like yeah Thomas
Massey has been posting about this and
that is that is kind of piece of in my
opinion that's like the most compelling
evidence because the bombs that were
placed around the capitol heightened the
entire situation to such a level that
you might be able to justify bringing in
federal troops or putting detaining
people without without charge or trial
Jim Gaffigan makes a good question he's
like why didn't Trump call anybody in
why didn't Trump just say get law
enforcement down there right now I think
it's fair to say that Trump was bumbling
quite a bit I don't think Trump had any
intention on anyone going into the
capital I think he genuinely had no idea
what was going on and I don't mean that
he didn't know there were people
storming the capital on one side and
going in another I'm saying he did not
comprehend the situation well have you
you've read though that apparently after
his speech he told Secret Service to
drive him to the Capitol and they said
no we're taking you pretty sure that was
a fake story oh was that because they
claimed that Trump like attacked the
driver well yeah it was exaggerated he
attacked the driver but what I what I
garnered what I gathered from that was
like if Trump did actually want to go to
the Capitol and talk to these guys could
have been a totally different outcome if
Trump was there and he was like hey guys
we want to do this peacefully as he was
probably still speaking when they were
breaching the capitol grounds oh okay
right but either way if he had gotten
there he could you know he could have
ended it
um and so it's weird that secret service
would say no we're not letting you go
and it's weird that Trump couldn't
override that with just a direct order
also so you know yep I got personal
criticisms I mean I wasn't the president
president had held a job during coveted
man but the way he didn't send in
federal troops during the Riots of 2020.
President did a hell of a job during
covet well no you think operation Wars
no I don't think he did a good job I
mean the president has a hell of a job
during something like that is what I
mean and he so I can't talk too much
about him and like be like well if
I was there I would have this and that
because like backseat driving to
hindsight's 2020. but he didn't send in
the troops day one of the 2020
insurrections whatever the hell these
these Street riots that broke out after
George Floyd death I would told Tim the
next day like where the National
Guard what are we waiting for this is
going to spread out of control this is
like a fire burning right now and it did
two days three days later two days later
the city's starting to get burned down
and I'm like where's the president of
the United States the armed chief of our
military committee